il existe plusieurs types de pollution
de l'eau de l'air la pollution lumineuse
et en écologie la question de la
pollution par le bruit est de plus en
plus étudiés les chercheurs constatent
d'ailleurs que les humains sont loin
d'être les seuls à être dérangé par le
bruit dans l'environnement
le silence dans les milieux naturels est
en train de disparaître
difficile de trouver des endroits où il
n'ya pas de pollution sonore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partout nous allons nous produisons du
bruit on commence à entendre de plus en
plus qu'on fait drôlement de ce tapage
[Musique]
notre société duty réalisé est de plus
en plus bruyamment terre si le bruit
provoque un inconfort pour nous on sait
maintenant qu'il dérange ou si la fondre
on a des preuves que ça affecte la santé
de plusieurs espèces animales
on est sur les berges du fleuve
saint-laurent tout près du pont
laviolette a trop bien
raphaël brouette un écologiste des
paysages il documente les interactions
entre les êtres vivants et leur
environnement
aujourd'hui ils mesurent le niveau de
bruit dans le fleuve quand une journée
comme aujourd'hui sous l'eau c'est très
bruyant on ne les fait des vagues les
navires marchands qui passent au large
on les entend très bien même en berge on
peut aussi entendre les vibrations du
pont donc jusqu'à un certain point le
trafic du pont peut se répercuter dans
l'eau à travers les vibrations des
piliers
des études démontrent depuis longtemps
que le bruit provenant de la circulation
maritime a un impact sur les mammifères
marins
le bruit des bateaux à un effet de
distorsion sur la communication entre
les baleines
[Musique]
raphaël proulx s'intéresse cette fois à
l'effet du bruit sur les poissons cela
peut paraître étonnant mais certaines
espèces ont une acuité auditive à s'y
développer ces espèces leur a fait ce
sont les chevaliers les meuniers tous
les poissons qu'on dit les
poissons-chats là mais les barbottes la
barbue et aussi tout le sprint vincent
peut être les cas les petits poissons
fourrage
on pense que c'est pour se déplacer
probablement trouver des sources de
nourriture
la navigation sous l'eau mais c'est
encore peu claires seulement pourquoi
ils ont une si bonne option
tout comme chez les baleines les
résultats de ces recherches prouvent que
la pollution sonore affecte aussi les
poissons nous ce qu'on a démontré ses
l'évitement ces espaces ans elles ont
tendance à plus évitez les endroits
classiquement élevé mais il ya encore
énormément de recherches afin justement
sur le stress sur les facteurs
comportementaux
[Musique]
si le bruit est très présent sous l'eau
sur terre il est aussi omniprésent
[Musique]
en idaho le chercheur justin bieber a
mené l'une des premières recherches nord
américaines sur l'impact du bruit sur la
faune terrestre
il a ciblé les oiseaux car l'idaho est
situé au beau milieu d'un couloir de
migration le long des montagnes
rocheuses entre le canada et le mexique
cette étude cherche à évaluer l'impact
du bruit sur les oiseaux on sait que les
pollutions chimiques et lumineuse les
affectent mais on voulait déterminer
quelles étaient les conséquences du mûri
sur eux parce que c'est maintenant et
polluant tellement présents dans
l'environnement
[Musique]
environ 80% des terres aux états unis se
trouve à deux kilomètres d'une route
principale ça signifie qu'à peu près
tous les êtres vivants subissent l'effet
du bruit de la circulation
le chercheur a donc voulu déterminer
comment le bruit d'une route passante
affecte les oiseaux il a développé un
projet appelé la route fantôme
nous avons enregistré le bruit émis par
des voitures roulant à environ 70
kilomètres à l'heure avec un microphone
très sensible ces fichiers audio ont
ensuite été diffusées par une trentaine
de hauts parleurs attachés à des arbres
ç'a permis de recréer le niveau sonore
générée par une autoroute dans un milieu
naturel
nous avons constaté que 30% des oiseaux
ont quitté les sites et que certaines
espèces ont carrément fui la région
lorsque nous avons mis en marche les
haut parleurs et les oiseaux qui sont
restés n'ont pas pris de poids en
d'autres mots leur condition physique ne
s'est pas améliorée c'est un réel
problème pour des oiseaux migrateurs qui
ont un long chemin à parcourir
pour le chercheur ces résultats sont
inquiétants car depuis des décennies le
bruit est en constante augmentation
notre société est de plus en plus
bruyante
la population des états unis s'est accru
du tiers depuis 1970 mais on se rend
compte que le nombre de kilomètres
parcourus en avion et en voiture a aussi
triple y répondre
nous avons perdu notre capacité à
écouter la nature sans l'interférence de
tous brûlés
il s'agit pas seulement des voitures
mais de la climatisation des avions des
traits c'est devenu presque impossible
de dénicher un endroit à l'abri de toute
pollution sonore
matthew mes consignes et son collègue
font de l'écologie acoustique il visite
aujourd'hui le parc national des
prairies dans le sud de la saskatchewan
le parc national des prairies est l'un
des derniers écosystèmes de prairies
naturelles en amérique du nord avant
l'arrivée de l'agriculture une grande
partie du continent était recouverte de
ce que l'on voit ici
quand le temps le permet on peut
entendre ce qui se passe à dix
kilomètres à la ronde
on est quelques uns ici dans le secteur
alors tout ce qu'on entend c'est le
bruissement de l'air pas d'autoroute
pote touristes
l'équipe fait partie de la fondation
coyette perks les parcs silencieux cet
organisme a pour mission d'encourager
l'établissement de réserve de silence
est loin d'être silencieux ici il ya le
vent qui souffle dans les arbres il y a
le hurlement des coyotes ilya tout ce
bruit que fait la nature et qui fait
partie du décor ça va de pair avec
l'endroit
des bruits comme ce que font les avions
ou les génératrices des motorisés n'ont
pas leur place ici ils n'ont pas évolué
avec cet écosystème
pour en arriver à déterminer le niveau
de silence du parc des prairies l'équipe
écoute et enregistre le son ambiant ici
lorsque nous cherchons à déterminer la
qualité du silence dans un lieu donné
nous mesurons ce qu'on appelle
l'intervalle cendres grâce à de
l'appareillage très sensible nous
calculons la durée d'une période de
silence entre le passage de deux avions
ou de deux voitures par exemple lorsque
nous obtenons un intervalle sans bruit
de 15 minutes ou plus on peut qualifier
ce lieu d'exceptionnel
l'éloignement du parc national des
prairies des routes principales son
emplacement en dehors des grands
corridors aériens et surtout le silence
qui règne rendent l'expérience
concluante la sainte paix comme on aime
le dire
lorsqu'on s'arrête et qu'on prend le
temps d'écouter cette nature tout semble
aller de soi tout semble à sa place je
pense qu'il était indispensable que tout
le monde puisse bien de cette expérience
derrière l'idée de ces réserves
silencieuse et de toutes les recherches
sur le bruit il y a une véritable
volonté de sensibiliser décideurs
citoyens ou campeurs moderne au fait que
le bruit est une nuisance pour nous mais
aussi pour tous les autres êtres vivants
si votre sol est contaminé votre rôle
est probablement aussi si votre eau est
polluée votre air l'est certainement
aussi et si vous avez de la pollution
sonore et bien vous avez tout ça
je pense qu'il faut voir le problème des
nuisances sonores de façon globale
nous sommes en pleine crise de
biodiversité nous alternons l'atmosphère
provoquant ainsi des changements
climatiques qui fragilise nos sociétés
tout est lié à l'industrialisation et à
notre dépendance à l'énergie fossile
lorsque nous nous attaquerons changement
climatique nous résoudrons en partie le
problème du bruit
[Musique]